Now watch another element. I'm going to
go a little deeper. And when he had said
this, he went out again to the Jews and
said to them, "I find no guilt in him.
But you have a custom that I release
someone for you at the Passover."
Notice, he announces he's the king. So
he got it.
"Are you a king?" "You yourself said I
am." By your own words, you confirm it.
"Do you wish then that I release for you
the king of the Jews?"
They cried again, saying, "Not this man,
but Barabbas." Now, Barabbas was a
robber.
Now, can I go a little deeper with you
guys?
Okay. Barabbas, right?
All right. You remember on Yom
Kippurim, the Day of Atonements,
Leviticus 16, there had to be two goats.
One
to be sacrificed and the blood present
on the altar to make atonement for all
of Israel if they repent and humble
themselves and fast.
Otherwise, they'd be rejected. The
other, where the high priest
Okay. Leviticus 16. I'll bring up the
article.
They would make lots.
One lot would fall on the goat that
would be slaughtered. The blood present
on the altar. The other lot would be
would fall on the goat for Azazel.
Azazel.
The goat for Azazel that would be
released in the wilderness, the high
priest would place his hand over the
goat, pronounce all the sins of Israel
on the head of the goat.
Okay, you with me there?
Okay. That act symbolized the goat
carrying the sins of the nation, that
the sins of the nation would be
transferred to the goat, and the goat
would then run off into the wilderness
where he'd eventually die, carrying the
sins of the people, removing their sins
far from them.
Right? You guys already know where I'm
going with this cuz I mentioned in the
past.
Two goats, right?
Okay.
You may not be aware of this, but there
are many manuscripts of Matthew 27:16-19
that tell you what Barabbas' full name
happens to be. Now note,
Barabbas,
bar Abbas,
Aramaic, bar Abba, son of the father.
Bar Abba.
Okay.
His full name is Jesus.
Yeshua bar Abba.
Jesus,
son
of the father.
He was full of sin, symbolized a nation
steeped in sin, and he was released.
The one who was sinless, he was
slaughtered.
That's how deep your Bible is.
Look at the footnotes to your Bibles,
which often you ignore,
and they'll tell you many manuscripts
read Jesus Barabbas.
Let me show you the NIV.
Okay.
And I have an article on this.
I wrote an article on this.
The scapegoat, Jesus as the scapegoat.
Now watch here.
Matthew 27:16-19.
At that time, they had a well-known
prisoner whose name was Jesus Barabbas.
Barabbas is Greek for bar Abba. Bar,
son. Abba, father. Two Jesuses, both
sons of
their fathers.
One sinless, slaughtered. The other
laden with sin, symbolizing a nation
full of sin and released with the sins.
The goat to Azazel.
Right?
You got it there?
So when the crowd had gathered, Pilate
asked them, "Which one do you want me to
release to you? Jesus Barabbas or Jesus
called the Messiah?"
Now, watch proof that Jesus, our Lord,
is the son of Abba. Here.
Mark 14:36. What does he say in Aramaic?
"Abba, father." He uses the Aramaic term
Abba.
Too much, right? Too deep?
You guys tired? You want me to end it
now? Yep, CJ just gave you a link to my
article.
Christ and Scapegoat. I give you the
details right there.
Stuff I've covered in the past about
creature repetition, right? I see Toma.
Two Jesuses,
both are called Barabba, son, bar, Abba,
father. One sinless, he was slaughtered.
The other laden with his sin,
symbolizing a nation full of sin and
released like the scapegoat was released
in the wilderness to Azazel.
Yep, that also ties in with the high
priest.
Yep.
High priest, that's another element. As
well as with Numbers
19.
Okay, now watch here. Leviticus 16.
Now watch here.
So when the crowd gathered, Pilate asked
them, "Which one do you want me to
release to you? Jesus Barabbas or Jesus
who was called the Messiah?" For he knew
it was out of self-interest that they
had handed Jesus over to him. While
Pilate was sitting on the judges' seat,
his wife sent to him this message,
"Don't have anything to do with that
innocent man, for I've suffered a great
deal today in a dream because of him."
Now let's see if Barabbas means what I
said or am I lying.
Too much meat to cover with you guys,
man. I'm the one who's fried. Pray for
my strength, my health, my energy, my
holiness, and my daughter's salvation.
Cuz I know you don't believe me cuz
you're a bunch of stinking haters.
Here you go.
Haters. Haters be hating.
All right.
Haters be hating.
Hate, hate.
Let's see what it is. Barabbas. Notice,
Yeshua called notable,
a prisoner,
right?
Baraban, Baraban, Baraban.
Baraban, Barabbas.
What is it?
Son of Abba.
What does Abba mean?
Son of Abba, Barabbas, right? Barabbas.
Of Aramaic origin, bar. What is bar?
Son.
What is Abba?
Father.
Perfectly being fulfilled in our Lord
Jesus Christ. Okay, we got that now?
Now let me see. Oh, by the way, did you
see that? Could you see the screen?
Baraban, Baraban accusative.
Barabbas
in the nominative.
Bar,
son of Abba.
It's Aramaic, Chaldee origin. Bar, son.
Abba.
Two goats on Day of Atonement.
The scapegoat where the high priest
would put his right hand upon that of
the goat, pronounce the sins of the
nation. So symbolically, the goat would
now be laden with the sins of the
nation, and he would carry off their
sins from them in the wilderness.
And the other goat
that would be slaughtered.
Two Jesuses, two sons of Abba. One laden
with sin, representing the nation,
released. The other sinless,
slaughtered.
This Bible's too supernatural.
It's too much.
It's too supernatural.
It's too much, man. It's mind-blowing.
Okay. Now watch Christ get
coronated, inaugurated for his
kingdom. You ready?
Kingdom.
Get ready.
Watch here.
Pilate then took Jesus and flogged him.
When the soldiers twisted together a
crown of thorns, here's his crown, they
put it on his head and put a purple robe
on him. Purple was the symbol of
royalty.
Purple was the symbol of royalty.
You with me there?
Here they are coronating him. His
coronation.
Thorns,
his crown,
robe that is purple, royalty. They're
coming to him saying, "Hail, king of the
Jews." You see?
And we're giving them slaps in the face.
And Pilate came out again and said to
them, "Behold, I'm bringing him out to
you so that you may know that I find no
guilt in him." Notice, he is sinless.
Jesus then came out wearing the crown of
thorns and the purple robe, royalty.
Pilate said to him, "Behold the man."
Ecce homo in Latin. Ha nasha.
So when the chief priests and officers
saw him, they cried out, saying,
"Crucify, crucify." Now watch. Pilate
said to them, "Take him yourselves I and
crucify him, for I find no guilt in
him."
The Jews answered him, "We have a law.
By that law, he ought to die because he
made himself out to be son of God."
Being the son of God was not punishable
by death unless you claimed to be the
divine son of God who was equal with
God.
So right here the Jews are testifying he
claimed to be the son of God in such a
way
that made him equal to the Father.
Now, watch how deep it gets.
Therefore, when Pilate heard this
statement, he became a more afraid. He
freaked out.
By the way, do you know what church
tradition says Pilate became a believer?
No, the Holy Spirit is the reason who
worked through me, brother.
You have something called The Acts of
Pontius Pilate.
All right?
There, it's supposedly recording
what Pilate claimed his wife saw.
And it also records
the teaching of Nicodemus.
You can find it online, read it.
Claiming what happened when Jesus died
and he went to the realm of the dead.
Yep, The Acts of Pontius Pilate. Do you
know why that was written?
You guys want to be shocked?
Do you know that Justin Martyr claimed
that there was an actual record written
by Pilate that was available in the 2nd
century for people to read where Pilate
recounts the miracles that occurred on
the day that Jesus was killed?
It's mentioned by Justin Martyr.
Do you know that?
Justin Martyr
mentions that at his time, the actual
record left by Pilate was still
available for public viewing. People
could go and check it out. Where Pilate
claims miraculous events took place on
the day Jesus was killed and the
Christians appealed to it as extra
biblical evidence
for the miraculous nature of Christ's
death.
Do you know that?
This is stuff you're not hearing, right?
So, then guess what the Christians did.
They then wrote up a document.
Right? The Gospel of Nicodemus, The Acts
of Pilate.
Where
they may have
used some of the material in The Acts of
Pilate to compile this document.
And where they mentioned
what Nicodemus taught.
And it recounts how Pilate converts to
Christianity and the things Jesus did
when he went to the realm of the dead.
You guys didn't know this, right?
Justin Martyr mentions it. And I'll find
it for you in a minute. In fact, you can
just Google it. Justin Martyr
mentions The Acts of Pilate confirming
the miraculous signs of the crucifixion.
It's there.
See that?
Now, how many of you are hearing that
for the first time today?
Lord Jesus Christ reigns. Are you
hearing that for the first time today?
So, Justin Martyr is defending the
Christian faith against Jews and the
Gentiles and trying to convince the
Roman Empire not to persecute
Christians, they pose no threat. Do you
think he's going to appeal to records
that don't exist
in making his case?
Do you think Justin Martyr is going to
appeal to fictional, non-existent legal
records by
right? Pilate
and embarrass himself and disgrace the
Christians because he's mentioning it in
the context of convincing unbelievers of
the truth of Christianity?
So, that means we can trust that such a
document existed and it continued
in circulation and was still
available
in the middle of the 2nd century.
Right? The cat's still hanging outside.
I'm waiting for the cat.
So, you you caught that?
So, you see how much evidence there is
because here
why did the Christians assume that
Pilate must have came to faith? Because
the Gospels show
that he is convicted. He realizes,
number one,
Jesus is innocent, sinless.
Number two, his wife suffered a
nightmare. God horrified his wife in a
dream warning her to warn him. We just
read it, Matthew 27:19. Don't mess with
him, he's innocent.
Right?
And here you see
that when the Jews told him he claimed
to be the son of God, being a pagan, he
understood that what they were claiming
is he's claiming to be a divine being.
Not a mere human, but a divine being.
And don't forget he remembered what
Jesus told him. My kingdom is not of
this world. You see what's happening to
Pilate?
Glory to God.
So, Pilate hears him say, "My kingdom is
not of this world."
So, what do you mean? Your kingdom is
heavenly?
You rule from heaven?
That means you're no mere human being.
And then they hear him
right?
Hear them he hears them say, "He claimed
to be the son of God and our law means
he's got to be killed." So, they
understood from the Jewish mindset,
uh-oh, he claimed to be divine. He's
claimed to be a divine being.
He told me his kingdom is from another
world, heaven. And now they're telling
me he's claiming to be the unique divine
son of God, meaning he's not merely
human. My wife had a dream that
horrified her warning her to warn me,
"Have nothing to do with this innocent
man." I'm in trouble, dude.
You see that rumble?
Go to Google right now. No, Gibson
everyone else, type in
Justin Martyr references The Acts of
Pilate.